Welcome to toss to Google,
I'm highly not. And then today
half the well known actor,
but now director,
writer and Songwriter Bradley Cooper
in our myths to discuss his directorial
debut film, a star is born,
which he also co wrote,
produced and stars in
along with the Fabulous Lady Gaga who
herself was here, wants to move forward.
Dave Chappelle, Sam Elliott
and other stars. So, but uh,
you've just seen his story.
So I think we're going to
invite Bradley on stage list.
Hey,
one of the nicest, hardest working
people in Hollywood. You're very real.
You keep it real.
You've had an arc as an actor that has
been impressive both on in theater and,
uh, numbers, uh, for
Academy award nominations,
I believe Baptist and so forth. But you've
entered this new realm of directing.
So you've kind of gone from
what we would call around here,
an individual contributor
role, the act, wow.
Two leader where you have to have a
vision and you need to fire people.
And then you have budgets
and you've got technology.
So were you at little bit scared going
into all this or how did it all roll out?
You're, you're absolutely right. The
first of all, thank you for having me.
It's such a pleasure to
be, oh, it's hardship
to how you can really,
no, it's Kinda, it's, it's insane.
Insane. And I was able to get,
you were kind enough to invite me this
lead to the Google camp when we showed
the movie,
which was really cool.
Everyone was buzzing about it. That was
very great. Not a dry I heard. Yeah.
My daughter loved it.
She is not the movie, but
it's a big pool there. Um, uh, um,
you're so right about budgetary
issues and timing and all and all,
all of that stuff. But I
actually loved all of that. Um,
I love to actually having a,
you know,
dipping my toe in all
of those aspects of it.
And I think that's because you're right,
when you,
when you have a vision and
you want to see it through,
I would feel very odd if I didn't,
if I didn't have a part of the,
it's cause that's part of the road.
And how wide it is and how,
how you know where the velocity picks up.
You want to have a say in
everything because it winds
up the finished product is
right now,
now belongs to you.
So I very much was a part of all of
that and I couldn't imagine not doing it
that way.
Anything really surprise you
about that process and journey?
I've seen so many interviews of the type
cast coming together and saying we had
a magic experience working as a team
working as a collaborative creative group.
It wasn't so much scripted as enabled
by a clear vision of the story and your
just freeing up lady Gaga,
Dave Chappelle to play their parts in
ways they said they'd never experienced
before and of course it's lady Gaga,
his first film debut.
So I think it has,
I think that's,
I've heard them say that that makes me
so happy because that's what the goal to
create an environment
where as you all know,
when you feel safe and you feel motivated
and you also know that you're called
upon to bring all of yourselves,
that that's the environment that you can
really thrive and you go home at night
and think, oh wow, that was
a really fruitful day. Um,
I think because I've been in
this business for 20 years, um,
and um,
I've been in brown all different types
of environments in the same setting.
Uh, I just, you know, I'm a
good listener and observer,
so I just watched and picked up
everything that works for me.
And I just wanted to create an environment
which was the culmination of all of
the good parts and take all
the bad parts out of it,
and then hope that in that respect,
I could get the best out of the people
that are entrusted themselves to me,
quite frankly, because that was, I mean,
I just couldn't believe that lady Gaga,
it took such a huge risk
because it's a big risk.
This isn't one of those projects
where you're like, well, you know,
if it doesn't work out, it'll, you'll
be okay. Like, not really. He's not,
it's not really this. It's like
actually if it doesn't work out, it's,
you're going to take a big hit. So,
so there was a lot at stake and I'm,
and even for Dave Chappelle, that took
me like two and a half years to get him.
And, um, because he just doesn't do this
kind of thing. And, but he was so willing,
and Sam Elliott,
you know,
I've never seen him play a character that
was so filled with resentment the way
that character was. And he just threw
all of themselves into that. And,
and then my hope is that it's because
they felt that there was that kind of
inspiring environment, which by
the way, I sort of set the tone,
but everybody else has to help create
that, you know, every single crew member,
everybody has to be on the same page and
everybody dictates, I mean, you know,
in your work environment,
if there's one person that has
an energy that's off the whole,
it contaminates the rest of the team.
So everybody really has
to be on the same page.
And you pursued this script for years.
I've seen various reports,
six years.
He said you proceed Dave
Chappelle for over two years.
So when did you get the burning idea to
do the fourth incarnation of a star is
born? It was, it was sort of like a
coming together of two different things.
I always knew I wanted to
direct, um, and I would,
I'd worked with great directors like
David O. Russell or Clint Eastwood,
who really allowed me to
be a part of their process.
I was in the editing room almost every
day for silver linings playbook and Jay
Cassidy, who was David said, or he, he
and I worked together on this movie. Um,
so I'd,
I'd,
I'd always knew that eventually I'm going
to have to stop just saying I'm going
to try to do and actually do it.
And because I knew that all these sort
of compositions cinematically would
always fly around in my head. And
I was at a Metallica concert, um,
and I was an, I had met Lars Olrick and,
uh, like the night before, and I said,
well man, I'm a huge Metallica fan
and a, and he said, well, come to the,
come to the concert tomorrow night.
So I found myself 12 hours later standing
behind his drum kit or Yankee stadium,
and I can see the sweat on his back and
I could also see the scope of the crowd.
And I thought, this is an incredible
composition that people don't get to see.
And that was the, that was
the, the, the birth of the eye,
the subjective idea of always being
on the stage four in the movie.
So in the movie were never in the crowd.
Um,
so it was just like little ideas
like that. I thinking about fame,
like what fame can be, um, you
know, Paparazzi and you know,
you can watch TMZ, but what is
it? What's the experience like in,
to me it's so it's sonic and it stayed
this cacophony of noise where it's like,
and then silence and that's the
opening of the movie is your, your,
your thrust onto this,
into this thunder dome with this guy.
And then all of a sudden you're into
this very small, almost like coffin,
like environment. And that, that's
an emotional juggernaut for people.
Uh, so that was something
I thought of early on.
And then there was just this property
and Warner brothers had and it,
and I thought, oh, I can explore
all of these things. Family Trauma.
What happens if two people actually
love each other? There's no infidelity.
It's actually true love. And
even with that, it's hard.
So these are things I wanted to explore.
And then this property was perfect because
it had music and you can't hide when
you sing. And I thought, well this is,
this would be the great way to do it.
So really was, it was really a
combination. I didn't think, I never,
I never ever thought like, you know,
it's a thing people should do the fourth,
the remake of a stars
definitely didn't do that.
And this is one like none other. So we're
all going to pay money to see it. Um,
you can't hide if you sing,
you just said that you didn't hide.
You studied boy,
you took voice lessons for 18 months.
You learn guitar and uh,
Lady Gaga required that
you take all of the,
do all of the singing live that
you weren't doubling it. Yeah.
So what was that all like?
Well, the music is a character
in the movie, you know,
it's not like with the movie takes a
break and then all of a sudden there's a
song, it actually has everything
to do with the, with what's
going on. It's almost,
it is a scene.
My favorite scene of Lady Gaga is actually
acting wise is the final song because
you, we watched this character go through
the grieving process through the song,
which I just, that's what a, what
a feat. Acting feet. She did.
So it would have been,
we had no choice but to sing live and
that's much easier for her. And I thought,
how the heck am I going to do
that? And you know, cause she,
and the other thing is
she's the real deal.
I know I had the nuclear
power of the movie. It's like,
well at least I have this.
I can,
if the movie sucks,
at least there'll be like 10 moments
where she's singing and it won't be
horrendous. But I knew I had to lift
the rest of the movie up to her level.
So you believe it. Otherwise, if you
don't believe me as this character,
you don't believe we're really on
stage seeing in front of people.
If you don't believe
that Saturday night live,
then there's no way I'm going to be able
to allow you to enter into this world
and learn about her. So there was really
no question that that had to happen.
It was great that she felt so
strongly about it as well. Um,
but it added,
I mean it's part of the DNA of the film.
It's a beautiful story of Jackson main
of Fading Country Music Star with the
alcohol problem and Allie who you discover
and encouraged and you see her rise
through the film.
So
20 when you say country stars. So
when we started, uh, writing it,
I was trying to figure out where he was
from and I quite honestly thought like
maybe it's country cause I could kind of
like kind of fake saying and like maybe
get away with it.
And then as I kept working and starting
to like fall in love and create this
character,
I swear if we had like six more months,
he would have been like
completely heavy metal,
like a cat guy.
Harder and harder and harder.
We've talked about this actually what
Genre Jack's music is because it's
definitely not country, right? Yeah.
Twain when you speak and
kind that ruddy red face,
that looks like you had too much.
But even with the twine scotch. That's a
good question. So in terms of his voice,
that was the hardest thing actually was
lowering my voice just about an octave.
And I wanted to pick an act, a voice that,
that you couldn't place geographically.
And Sam Elliott wound up being the,
before I even thought about writing the
role for him, the voice that I studied.
So I would get all of these tapes
of Sam Elliott and abuse was,
and then it got him and then, and then
I was doing it and it, cause he's,
he's born in Sacramento, which you never
know he's from, he's from California,
but his mother was from Texas,
so he's got this odd accent
that you can't really place.
And then I was reading Bruce Springsteen's
autobiography and he was talking
about stealing his father's voice.
That's what he did as a kid.
Nice to always want to be
my dad. And I thought, oh,
what if Sam Elliott is his older brother?
And he stole his voice.
And so that's how that
whole thing happened.
Wow.
You're so you both visualize and you
have auditory things going through your
creative process. Yeah. It
sounds like speaking about,
um,
auditory,
there's someone in the audience who
gradually lost her hearing as a child and
has, is impressed by how accurately you
portrayed the frustration and denial.
Many people experience when losing
their hearing. So her question is,
do you have any personal experience with
hearing loss and how did you study to
portray that aspect of the
role so authentically? Yeah.
Hmm. Oh, well, I'm glad that you
thought that it was the person here. Hi
Bradley. Nice one. Yeah. Um,
I'm glad you felt that way.
I was born and here's the other thing.
When you get to write the movie,
you can just cheat all the time because
you just do everything that's real to
you. Like his choice of drink
is crazy personal for me.
That's my dog, Charlie.
That's my real dog. Um,
a bunch of my friends are in the movie,
um,
who I went to Grad school
with and the hearing loss,
I wanted him to be like a prize fighter
because in the other versions of the
movies, he's so obsessed with fame and
this fames dwindling. And I didn't want,
I had no interest in, in investigating
that. And also people today,
everybody makes money touring.
And a lot of these bands that have
been maybe huge back 20 years ago,
it was still making a lot of money
touring. So the reality was he's fine.
Um,
so it was more about what's,
what's the wear and tear and
it takes a toll on your body.
And I interviewed and spend time with
tons of musicians and the thing that
happens is hearing loss. That's the number
one thing that goes, which makes sense.
Um,
but I was born with a clause to youtome
in my ear drum and it was removed.
And then I was kind of a car. I would
always jump off a high places as a kid.
Don't ask me why. And I kept puncturing
it. And so I had all these operations,
like five operations.
I have a hole in my right ear.
So when he's telling her that story in
the bar, that's me. That's all real.
That's like, so, yeah. Um, and so
I have, I don't have hearing loss,
but I that when I have ear infections,
I hear that tonight is sound,
so I know it very well. Um, and then
it was all about in the mixing stage,
creating, recreating that sound
sonically for the audience.
So I'm glad you felt that way.
Thank you.
Beautiful.
You talked about in one of the interviews
I saw you just want it to be in this
to create and make it real. So the
backstory, you bring a bunch of friends,
some graduate school friends from uh,
New York City city. Yeah. There's the,
I just studio the studio.
And you've been collecting people
like Sam Elliott and Gaga over it,
period.
I did a TV show alias and two of those
actors are in the movie run Rifkin and
Greg Rumberger.
Wow. Yeah. So that can
just be happenstance.
So you've been collecting
talent and ideas. Yes. Um,
what was the moment you
knew you could make it real?
Was it when Warner greenlit it or was
it just when you knew you had enough
conviction about envision for this
film that you could pull it off?
I think it was working with directors who
were allowed me to be so collaborative
with them. I think if it
wasn't for David O. Russell,
there's no way I wouldn't have
had the confidence. But he really,
it was like going to film
school doing those three movies,
particularly the two movies,
a silver linings playbook
and American hospital. Um,
and I really got it and, but,
but even when I did alias,
I would, I hated La and I,
and I like knew no one so,
and I only worked three days a week
and I just moved there for the tea,
this television show.
So I would just spend all my time on
set and in the editing rooms and I would
get everybody's dailies back.
I would take them home.
And that was when they were on VHS tapes.
So I was always fascinated
by the process. Got It. Um,
so I think it was just a constant, you
know, just sort of, um, uh, you know,
listening and observing.
It's once Ferrell Williams came
to visit us and he said, you know,
you people are creatives,
you just do it with your mice,
which is actually a
cinnamon for coding I guess.
But there is some analogy editing and uh,
knowing what the end
product you're looking for.
And it's a very technical
process from just the
according to sponsors to color.
Oh yeah.
Are you expert at that at this point or
is that something that is also in its
own way,
a collaborative effort?
I mean, everything's a
collaborative effort, but um, no, I,
we spent months and months, I mixed every
single car exhaust in this movie. Yeah.
Because the, the, the film
itself is one musical element.
That's how it's all rhythm. Everything
is rhythm and joy in life and, and,
and especially a film. It has to be one
musical elements so that you're not,
you know, you're not bumping up against
the guard rails while you're watching it.
You feel like you're in good hands.
Those are the best movies that I like
to watch. This I just, Oh right. I,
the rhythm is very, is very set. Um,
and you create that in the editing room.
That is where you create it.
And then you had the bold move of actually
filming at Glastonbury and Coachella,
which at Glastonbury in the UK,
the biggest festival music festival
needs every summer. What was that like?
That's a real,
that's a real deal.
And that really came out of necessity,
which I'm sure you're all aware of it,
you know, sometimes, you know,
an idea comes out of what you can't do
and that we had a limited budget and
limited time and I thought,
well, it has to be real.
And I watched so many movies that had
recreated live performances and you can
really smell when it's not
working. And uh, I thought,
and actually Terrence Malick had just
done a movie about songwriters and I had
happened to see the trailer and
I thought, and I said, oh, he's,
so I called him and he was having, he was
kind of to talk to me and he said, yeah,
I've jumped on.
But it's very difficult.
But so that gave me the
confidence that it's doable.
And I go to Glastonbury every year cause
I'm a huge music fan and that's how I
knew them and they were, they
let me go on. But that was crazy.
We had four minutes in front of 80,000
people in the pyramid stage and it was a,
it was, yeah, it was really something
looking at it this way out onto the crowd.
Yeah,
but just getting real,
just getting back for a second to
what you were talking about earlier.
That's one of the things that I really
do love about the movie is when he,
when Jackson says to him, the boy in a
talent comes everywhere, but you know,
everybody's got talent,
but having something to say in a way
to say it so people listen to it.
That's a whole other bag that,
that's something that we
all have the ability to do.
You know that if there's one thing that
I hope people take from the movie is
that they go, yeah, fine,
what is it that you want to say
and how do I want to say it? Um,
and the Metta that I think is that lady
Gaga did that in this movie and I was
able to do that, that we helped
each other do that in this movie.
Very cool.
Um,
there's something about determination
and grit that has to go into pulling off
something that's epic,
but also you kind of jumped
out of your actors skin and,
or the place that you were fans for these
past 20 years have had you as an actor
and theater performer into this surprise.
He's also a great director.
There's a lot of press around you,
just the shots close in shots,
lingering shots,
like just intense visual experience.
That is all of a sudden you are
on in your first go at this.
Of course you've been in film for a while,
but talk to us a little bit
about that journey that it,
did it require grit,
self-belief.
Did you ever doubt yourself and are you
surprised now at the reaction of the
critics and the press around wow.
Like it's a new Bradley.
I figured it,
you know Ellie,
because van said if you're going to
audition to play a cowboy show up with the
horse because people only
know what they see. So,
so for me it wasn't a shock because I've
been thinking about shots since I was a
kid, you know, and observing movies and
seeing like, and the movies that I love,
his form always follows function
and arbitrary cool shot.
If I'm watching a movie and then I'm
aware as I'm watching the movie, Oh,
that's a cool shot. I'm, to
me that's not enjoyable. As a,
as a viewer of a film,
I want to,
I want to sort of afterwards when I'm
thinking about how I felt emotionally,
I said,
oh well Martin Scorsese,
that was one shot as they
went into the Copacabana. Oh
Wow. Right. You know, that's,
that's the, that's the goal. So
there's no, so I, you know, it's,
and it's all character
based for this movie.
Jackson takes his hat off when he's on
stage, he wants to avoid the camera.
She doesn't even,
she's not even aware of her talent,
but the movie's telling
you in the beginning,
she comes out of the bathroom and
she's in the center of the procedure.
She's on the stage already, even
though she's in the bowels of a, of a,
of a building in the bathroom.
So you could do things like
that cinematically with shots,
but it's all based on story.
And then by the end of the movie,
he can't avoid the camera anymore.
So when he's in the bed with her,
the cameras right on top of
him that he can't escape it.
So the hope is that you're feeling these
things, but you're not quite sure why,
but it's because I'm
manipulating it through the
choice of the shot. And that's,
that to me is what's fun about
telling a story cinematically.
That's the whole point.
Otherwise,
I never would have tried to direct a
movie if I didn't have a point of view of
how I wanted to shoot it.
I asked you earlier in what
we called the green room, um,
whether you're still playing to sing,
uh,
play the guitar and you said there's
one song you want to go finish in the
studio.
So talk to us a little bit about that
journey and whether you do it in the
shower or you're gonna get
you come to the studio permanent.
I did sing shallow in the shower,
the hotel the other night. I was
like, can I still sing that song?
It was okay. I think when in the
shower, it all sounds good, doesn't it?
Um, no, I don't think, I mean,
here's the thing I love about what I
get to do for a living is I get to enter
into a world like, like a
sociologist, you know, and,
and learn about everything and,
and soak it and not just cerebrally but
also since Suriya Lee and then then then
get to transferred into some
sort of ritualistic performance.
So it's a wonderful way of learning.
And this was incredible.
It took four years,
six years when I thought it,
that's when I was at the
concert with Metallica.
And the truth is I've been lucky enough.
There's something else that I feel
that obsessed by now. So I'm Kinda my,
my head and my heart is
somewhere else now. And the,
and I only know how to do this if I am
completely in love with it because as you
said, it's true. It takes a
tremendous amount of work. I mean,
I edited the movie in My house,
thank God because we were pulling 16 hour
days for like six months. Wow. And um,
and I just had a kid
so there was that too.
I'm always wondering if she's going to
like grow up in like, oh cause of the,
cause we, we edit, it's loud. It was
right below her bedroom and I thought, oh,
she's going to hear this music for like
the first six months of her life and
what her, she's going to like
hate our music or love it.
Yeah. Um, so, so I don't,
I don't know how to do anything to this
degree unless I completely love it.
That said, um, I
absolutely enjoyed singing,
but I hope that what I want to do
at least for the next decade or two,
is to make movies. Um, but there was
that song too far gone. That's in the,
the cop far. And I only wrote
the first verse and Chorus.
And I had the other day I had this
thought of the second verse and a bridge.
So I'm going to go,
he's a songwriter.
Multitalented you,
you just said you are a bit obsessive.
So what are you obsessing about now?
I don't want to say because
if it doesn't happen,
all right, but hopefully you'll
like it in five years. You know,
a number of us have watched your career
and know your characters so well.
And I remember a wedding crashes you
played so effectively it despicable guy.
It was
that football game.
Yeah.
And it's like put his tie over when he
would beat somebody up, it made no sense.
Just like sweat messaged Ohio.
Well,
what's your favorite character
that I played as a Jack Jackson
to say, I think it's still a Joseph
Merrick when I did the elephant man. Yeah,
that makes sense. Yeah. That
was a year long run on Broadway.
Broadway in London.
Yeah.
That's a lot of effort because
sometimes two shoes day.
So you made a specific choice and making
Jack Jackson's character and alcoholic
and a drug addict who's more rows and
verbally cruel, but he's not violent.
So someone has asked this question,
it seemed to me you were
pointing to the power of words.
Could you talk about the development and
nuance of building that character? Yeah,
absolutely.
To me, he's a, I mean it's for you
now, but to me, he's a character who's,
who's stuck at 13,
14 years old when that
traumatic experience happen
to them and everything comes
from that.
And he hasn't cultivated any other
aspect of his life except for his music
because the world was telling
him this is what is important.
That this is what we want from you.
And he was able to share that.
Now he's 43 and we meet him and he could
tell his body is starting to take a
toll,
has hearing,
and this gets old if you don't
cultivate the rest of your life. Um,
but he, to me, he's somebody that,
that's what he loves and he still has
an interest in people and music and,
and love of the work.
Um,
and that's why he's the sort of blown
away by her, but he's nothing. He's an I,
you know, I don't seem
as cruel at all. In fact,
the only really cruel thing he says
is that horrible thing he says in the
bathtub, but she doesn't even remember
cause he's so he's intoxicated. Um,
but even the way he says
that it's almost in this,
it's not an ad. It's not in an
aggressive way. It's, you know, so,
so I never saw him as, as he, first
of all, he's also not a word Smith.
He's not somebody who talks a lot,
you know, he chooses his moments,
you know what I mean? Um, I
just, I, I feel a lot of, um,
I care about him a lot. I just wish that
he was taking care of more, you know,
by his older brother,
you know, by himself too. I think
that's an important lesson to us all.
Once Allie is discovered,
um,
we do see Jack's hesitant
reaction to her transformation.
What should we understand about alleys
reaction and also like lady Gaga,
his own experience in that
character transformation,
which doesn't really parallel
her own. No, not at all. Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
The main difference with the other movies
I think are these two characters that
that's where we're sort of circling
around and the other movies,
the male character is,
I'm jealous of her fame and doesn't like
that he's losing the spotlight and she
is a character who sort of an
ingenue and looks at the world.
The world is my oyster. I Dunno what's
going to happen, but this is all great.
These two characters, it's a guy
who doesn't even think about fame.
It's a byproduct that he's had to deal
with. Um, he just cares about sort of,
I'm trying to find a
pure moment to fuel him.
She's somebody who's 31 years old and has
been told by the world or by corporate
music driven by men that her physical
appearance does not merit her song writing
ability.
So she won't shoot.
They don't want her to sing the
very songs that she's written.
And so she's relegated to singing in a,
in a,
in a bar and a dark bar and singing
a cover, not even her own music.
So that's a totally different character.
That's a character who's just about
given up, but she can't quite give up.
She still has that need to perform,
but it's, it's, it's in this,
it's tucked away in this little corner.
And so that's what I loved about this
story is these two characters meet and
when she's thrust into this world,
that is the, the con, you know, the,
the mechanized world of
music in a way. Um, she's,
she's taken a different direction,
but we were,
I was always conscious that she
still had a voice in it. You know,
when they have that fight in
the bath though, she says,
yeah, those are my lyrics.
You have a problem with my lyrics.
You know,
her manager wanted her to go blind
and she moved, went red. You know,
she still had a choice, but she did
sort of lose her weight as one does,
but a wayward road, a career. And I always
thought thought that was a shortcoming,
you know,
is that just because she's doing something
else doesn't mean that it's not as
truthful.
It's just the road is very winding.
Our target's going to be aired on Youtube,
which has on any day more
than a billion and a half, uh,
viewers around the world and the big hair
and big plot point in our movie. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I'd love to just ask
you what you think this,
the platforms that we have now,
these technical platforms,
but youtube in specific,
how has it enabled to creativity?
How,
how do you view it?
Do you spend time consuming content on,
I mean, [inaudible] they're a
device. The, in its best form, what,
what these platforms and technology
has given us is the, the,
the means by which we can, uh,
create story in, in various forms,
which is incredible. Um, I was talking
to somebody a yesterday in Dallas about,
you know,
what took Stanley Kubrick six years to
develop because he wanted to have some
sort of flowing shot you could do with
your iPhone now. Um, and then the,
and then you could post it.
And the fact that that you can get
content out there is, is this incredible.
So it kind of goes back again.
You just have to figure out what it is
you want to say and how to say it because
of the means by which you can tell that
story are at our disposal. You know,
it's almost too easy. That's the
other thing about shots. It's like,
but form to me at least form
still has to follow function.
It all still has to do with what is it
that you want to say and how do you want
to say it? And then use technology in
order to help you know, convey that.
Well, Bradley, thank you so much for
having something beautiful to say.
And the way in which you say
it in a star is born is, uh,
is people are reacting in rapture.
It opens October 5th.
Uh, we can't wait. Those of us weren't
here to see the preview, to see it live,
and I just want to thank you for coming
to Google and thank you. Thanks. Right?
Yeah.